with more on ukraine charlie dagda is
there for us today he visited a factory
that makes tanks for the country's army
the ukrainian people are preparing for
the worst military reservists up to age
60 are being called to serve and the
government may soon announce a state of
emergency charlie has more on the hopes
for peace and the preparations for a
possible conflict
good morning we are at a tank factory
here in the capitol it's here that they
service tanks and armored vehicles fresh
from the front line some of its
maintenance some of it is combat damage
they're already working overtime and
they're preparing for the worst in the
days and weeks to come
with diplomatic talks up in flames the
threat of wider sanctions alone is the
only thing standing in the way of
russia's war machine
threats that have so far been no answer
to stop their dramatic escalation and
shelling in the east
i have a bad feeling says luhan's
resident tatiana i feel the burden in my
soul it's very difficult
it's about to get more difficult with
russian lawmakers giving vladimir putin
the go-ahead to use military force
outside his country the gloves are off
new satellite photos appear to show the
deployment of more than 100 military
vehicles and dozens of tents for troops
along the border of belarus
and russian forces have been seen
advancing toward the battlefields of the
separatist regions in eastern ukraine
at least putin can no longer hide behind
russian-backed rebels says political
analyst terrace berazovic there are now
no more russian proxies no more
russian-backed separatists it's only
russia so russia is fully responsible
for whatever happens now in donetsk and
luhans completely no any proxies who
putin can point to and said it's not me
no russian troops ukrainian president
vladimir zelinski has called on
reservists to get ready to fight
ukraine is a peaceful nation he said we
want calm but if we keep silent now we
will be extinct tomorrow
which makes the work here at the tank
factory that much more urgent they need
every tank and armored vehicle battle
ready for the front lines knowing full
well this factory itself may be a target
in a full-scale invasion
we've learned the russian government
ordered the evacuation of all staff at
the embassy here in the capitol and
there are reports employees destroyed
documents as they headed for the exits
dana
charlie dagetta and ukraine thank you
charlie